it's your quick and easy Kardashian  ketchup here's what's going on with  America's most famous family welcome to  my house at Christmas  first Kris Jenner is famously all about  the holidays and is showing off her  Christmas decorations for Architectural  Digest a glass bear moving reindeer not  surprisingly they're over the top she  called me from Paris one day and said we  have this shot at getting the guy from  Paris to make you a bear and an upcoming  new year might mean new love 37 year  olds Kourtney Kardashian has been  spotted out and about with a younger man  a 23 year old model really cute but all  is not well with all kardashian  relationships  it doesn't stop Rob and blac Chyna have  had a tumultuous last few days with  China moving out of their home e is  reporting the couple had a physical  fight before China left their source  alleges China had been drinking and was  quote punching Rob  [Music]